[Musique]
oh
oh oh
où
oh
alors mon papa à mon papa c'est pas un
grand monsieur pour moi je le vois très
grand effectivement puisque mon déjà
fermé 90 quand même et basse et j'ai eu
la chance au delà de baigner dans une
famille très très équilibré avec ma
maman et mon papa qui faisait de la
musique font toujours de la musique en
vrai et qui m'ont vraiment
appris à
le faire très tôt en fait voilà donc
deux petites j'ai manifesté sa et ils
m'ont toujours soutenu et mon père c'est
vrai combat c'est celui qui voilà qui
joue au piano donc petit je voulais
faire comme papa joue au piano monter
sur ses genoux il écrivait sur les noms
sur les notes les noms des notes ou que
je retienne et où il y avait des codes
couleur elle avait plein de petites
techniques comme ça et puis
ouais les trajets de voitures aussi jean
alain l'école en général c'est du dit
mam nay ou mais qui me ramenait on
écoutait énormément de musique me
faisait me disais bon voilà tensions
entre la 10 mois quel instrument il ya
et je devais citer tous les instruments
qu'ils avaient été tous ou bien on
devait s'entraîner à trouver des tierces
des 15,1 des voix et c'est s'amuser mais
on s'amuse beaucoup jusqu'à maintenant
voiture en général on sait le monde
écoute de la musique que je m'embarque
dans la voiture et je lui ai dit bon
voilà je te fais écouter 5 trucs et puis
voilà qui lui aussi me fait écouter des
trucs et puis voilà j'ai juste très
chanceuse très fier de mes parents
j'espère qu'ils seront fiers de moi et
je sais faire mon papa une très bonne
fête je laime très fort il le sait on se
l'est dit très souvent et puis bien sûr
groggy dans la maman que j'aime aussi
très très très fort il voit là
[Musique]